do you think there was any any purpose
at all in accord or possess
brutalization to control opposition at a
chiral thought planing that's what an
amount and they're very indiscriminant
in their brutalization they want to get
anybody they can just just add on an
excuse and they have this mill over
there and when you go through the mill
you've been worked over it says that's
that's what it is you want to work over
and they all right arrest you at all no
no they just threw me out and it had my
coat over my head I couldn't see what
the hell I was doing and
they were I think it was one fellow was
just about to arrest me and then I think
he decided not to I started complaining
about my umbrella being missing in my
scar from my package and thing I think
they all of a sudden why stuff that they
had somebody that they didn't maybe what
I have yeah